USA Today is reporting Home Depot is
doling out bonuses of up to $1,000 to us
hourly workers becoming the last major
national employer to hand out checks
after president Trump's corporate tax
cut the home-improvement chain said it
would also continue to distribute
success sharing payments tied to the
company's financial performance profit
sharing yeah at Walmart bonuses of up to
$1,000 were distributed to workers with
at least 20 years of experience most
workers were eligible for a few hundred
dollars Walmart also increased its
minimum wage to $11 Starbucks announced
Wednesday it would give hourly workers
$500 bonuses and spend a hundred 20
million on wage hikes dozens of other
major national employers have also
announced bonuses or wage increases
including JPMorgan increase Walt Disney
Company and Wells Fargo economists have
argued that wage increases are more
meaningful than one time bonuses because
they're permanent retailers are among
the biggest winners from Trump's TaxACT
they typically pay high tax rates and
thus will benefit most from the rates
cut from 35 to 25 Home Depot says still
calculating the effect of the corporate
tax cut it expects a positive impact and
its sharing of course all success with
their team so it kind of defeats the all
those mean old companies if you let them
keep money that's theirs they will just
keep it they're just greedy argument the
evil GOP tax cut it just defeats the
argument I mean it's it doesn't matter
what your politics are you have to look
at the actual reality the actual facts
of what occur and it's a mathematical
thing for some people you know for
instance I don't run Home Depot I mean I
run a little company here i company's
about 700 people okay and couple hundred
million a year you know it's it's not
anywhere near like a home depot but I
promise you this morning I was sitting
in their operating
or meeting and we were looking at an
investment that we're getting ready to
do that will allow us to hire about 40
more people because of the investment
and I turn I look at my CFO and I said
well with the GOP tax cut are we gonna
have any money to do that with is that
gonna help and his answer was it'll
almost pay for it so that's 40 jobs I
didn't get that money and go oh I need
to buy me something and I'm a business
owner I mean I can buy me something if I
wants my stuff it's my money shut up but
if I don't want to buy me something and
I want to grow my business I can invest
in my business if you let me keep my
money and don't send it to Washington
about $20,000 toilet seats because those
idiots up there don't know how to spend
anything you figured that out right I
mean even if you're like completely
left-wing you have to admit that they're
really crummy at handling money up there
I mean if you if your brain is plugged
in at all you have to just look at the
evidence and go they suck at handling
money and so every module er you send up
there it's it limps at best back out
into the economy if it makes it back out
under the economy at all because they'll
just chop it up into little pieces and I
mean I mean some people know how to make
money some people know how to make it
disappear they know how to make it
disappear businesspeople seem to know
how to make money here's what's
interesting okay let me tell you about
Starbucks Home Depot and Walmart they
employ people the very nature of the
type of person that the the life
situation that their typical employees
in means that they have those three
companies have three of the highest
turnover of employees of any type of
company out there retail and the
restaurant world right so Starbucks
Walmart Home Depot I mean Walmart has
like a 200% turnover in a year on
average I mean that that's their average
so that means that some people leave
they have to hire three positions that
three people that year to fill that
position
and then they've got people that been
with them 25 years and it's not because
they're bad company it's the nature of
the the of somebody says okay I'm gonna
go get a job of Walmart now you know
some people say that and I'm gonna get a
job at Home Depot I'm gonna go get a job
at Starbucks most people that do that
don't say I'm gonna get a job at
Starbucks and work there 25 years and
working my way up into the Home Office
no they go I'm gonna go make some coffee
because I need some money and then if I
want to quit later I'll quit I'm gonna
work at Home Depot on the weekend I want
to quit later I'll quit there's nothing
wrong with that I tell people get extra
job all the time and those are three
great companies to work for they're all
three good companies so but here's the
thing that turnover ratio costs those
companies a lot of money because they're
constantly having to spend money to hire
and recruit and hire and recruit when
they pay more you know what it does
their turnover ratio drops it so save
some money so they're able to invest
that money by paying better not out of
the goodness of their heart it's not
just generosity they didn't just give
the money away they paid somebody for
working they paid them more for working
it's a business decision and it's not
it's not that they're evil people it's
just it you know this sometimes means
people say well you know the GOP thing
that causes people to be generous night
was not generosity you know I if I pay
someone more here it's usually because
our freaking want them to stay hello and
somebody else is willing to pay them
more it's an economic decision you know
and so I pay them more then somebody
else would pay them and that keeps them
here that's part of the thing now not
everybody stays just because of that and
very few people would stay because of
that only if they were being abused in a
bad cultural situation and all that's a
great culture we were in best place to
work every year all that kind of stuff
but you know but then you got to pay
them you got to pay people and the more
you pay them the Lowther turn lower the
turnover is assuming you've got a good
culture so it's a business decision but
it's interesting they were able to make
that decision to give these people
bonuses or raise their minimum wage to
$11 or different things and and because
they didn't get their money taken away
from them
and so if those people that work there
make more money what happens to that
money do they keep it they hoard it no
they go buy another pair blue jeans they
put gas in their car they go to a
restaurant when you go to a restaurant
and you give somebody to the restaurant
your money because you made a little
more money because you work at Home
Depot and you got $1,000 bonus what
happens at the restaurant
oh they the waiter gets paid oh the cook
gets paid oh the hostess gets paid the
general manager gets paid when they get
paid what happens to their money
oh they buy their kids clothes and the
guy that works at the factory making
kids clothes gets paid and the guys
selling it gets paid and the guy who
drives the truck that delivers the
clothes gets paid none of this happens
when you send it to the government this
is common sense y'all that's why they
call it currency it has a flow to it
unless you put it in a dead-end pond
with scum on it called Washington so
that's why this is working why all these
people are getting paid because these
people have more money to pay people
happened here today and that an odd
thing right here in this building today
Wow just like that I have more money
what I do with it
I'll cap it all cuz I'm greedy no we
figured out a way to hire 40 more people
this is the Dave Ramsey show